The world is more mobile than ever,
but increase mobility has also brought
congestion,
high emissions and poor air quality with
a number of cars on the road set to
quadruple by.
2050 mega cities such as Los Angeles in
Sao Paolo are becoming gridlock and road
speeds in London are approximately the
same as they were a century ago,
11 miles an hour.
If mobility is to remain the lifeblood
of our economy,
we need smart deliverable solutions.
Car sharing pioneered by organizations
like Zipcar and buzz car could be one
answer.
Every shared car takes 15 private cars
off the road.
Driverless cars are also gaining
momentum as a safer,
cleaner,
and more efficient way of getting
around.
A recent study has shown that by
managing their own speed,
cars increase efficiency by over 40%
this number rises to 273% when the cars
work together,
their sky tram,
a system of personal jetson style
transit pods set for a trial run in Tel
Aviv gliding above congested streets at
a hundred miles an hour or faster,
they can achieve the equivalent of over
200 miles per us gallon.
Not all solutions are high tech shared
space projects in city centers,
strip away traffic lights along the
traditional barriers between vehicles
and pedestrians.
The result is increased mobility through
a sense of shared risk.
Shell is working with partners to
innovate mobility.
That means moving higher volumes of
people and goods safely,
cost effectively and with reduced
environmental impact.
The Shell Eco Marathon challenges
student engineers and scientists from
around the world to design and build
vehicles to meet this demand.
The prizes are awarded to the teams that
go the furthest using the least amount
of energy Shell Scenarios Team Examines
Tomorrow's problems today.
Their latest set of scenarios shows that
if we build more compact cities,
we could reduce car use by around 2000
vehicle kilometers per person per year,
and that by 2070 the passenger rode
market could be nearly oil-free.
Smarter Mobility solutions are growing.
Click here to watch the latest switched
on event where five innovators and
thinkers present their own ideas for the
future of trans.